Germany and China's national flag side
by side is becoming a frequent sight
German President Joachim Gauck has just
been here half the cabinet will soon be
in Beijing for joint consultations right
now it's frankfurter Stein Myers turn
Germany's top diplomat welcome China's
apparent readiness to play a more active
role in global conflicts even when
Beijing's interests aren't directly
affected he not yet saw for the first
time China has just appointed a special
envoy to Syria that only serves to
emphasize that China wants to provide
support in the search for urgently
needed solutions to this big intractable
conflict without our major international
partners China among them we will not
find a solution that socialism
initiative under the two countries are
already cooperating at a multilateral
level Beijing is chairing the g20 this
year Berlin takes over in 2017 but
China's internationalism has clear
limits they lie in the South China Sea
and its myriad of competing territorial
claims baron you're gone you're going
out to you if some countries try to
bring historical issues into the g20
meetings for political reasons or even
over territorial and sovereignty issues
that's not only detrimental to the
solution of these issues it will likely
have an impact on regional stability
irrespective of the pronounced all-round
strategic partnership China continues
being a difficult and complex partner
however there are areas of mutual
interest even common grounds for
instance on the subject of clean energy
fine spring weather in the Chinese
capital belies an inconvenient truth
even on a day like this the air quality
is awful fine particle levels exceed
what is generally considered safe the
Chinese people are no longer prepared to
accept that politicians are under
pressure to act Germany's push to
restructure is energy market
seen as a source of hope for many in
China even if what's on display here is
an uninspiring exhibition but if
dialogue ensues over environmental
issues perhaps one day other topics
might be up for discussion like human
rights sometime soon